THE LOSS AGAINST BOSTON  LIKE T
GAME
WENT SEE IF THE
THE BUMPER SPOT JUMPS OUT AND
ATTACKS  CHALLENGE THERE
THEY GO AGAIN SUZUKI HAS THOUGH
ABOUT IT BECAUSE
SCORED ON CONSECUTIVE SHOTS IN
THE 2nd  PERIOD FOR MONTREAL IS
EKHOLM TO OPEN
UP WATCH HE'S  CORNERMING IN FO
CANADIAN. E NICELY GREAT THERE
EVANS GETS IT AFFECTS SAROS'
ABILITY TO MAKE THE SAVE AND
YOU CAN SEE SASA BOX SO YOU
HAVE TO BE CERTAIN EKHOLM
BACK TO HISIGHT BLASTING TO THES
JOSI, STOPS, SHOOTS. HALF BUT T
ON THE SCOREBOARD AS WE REACH
THE TEN MINUTE MARK. AT THIS
AGAIN YOU A
LONG TIME HIS FIRST SAVE OF THE
3rd  PERIOD. TION LOOKING FOR
THEY MOVE ONEXTREMELY
TIRED HANG ON TOINCREDIBLE.
POSSESSION BACK TO MONTREAL.
BACKUP THE BOARDS WE GO. LOOKIN